what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg here today I'm going to do a first
time watching for a movie I have had on my
list for a while since I'm out of town at
the moment this video is going up I was like
what's what's near the top of the list and
it's the Naked Gun got quite a variety of
movies going up at the moment I've never seen
it and I hear it's a fun one and I could use
a good comedy right about now so ladies and
gentlemen leave a like I know you can do it
consider your Christmas present to him what
also subscribe and click that notification
Bell to get notified when we got a reaction
up or something else or if there's this guy
if we do others subscribe and also full interaction
watch as long as we single with your own copy
of the Naked Gun available for super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page that's where
all of our full-length Reaction watch Longs
ago along with several shows where we do reaction
highlights and watch along to concluded exclusively
for those series already my intro is done
it's time to watch The Naked Gun let's see
if this movie is actually as good as people
have foreign [Music]
no longer willing to fight [Music]
goddamn American Hero [Music] he aimed way
too high [Music] hahaha
[Music] classic
I lost 23 pounds ask me how
[Music]
[Laughter] I'm Lieutenant Frank Dragon police
squad and don't ever let me catch you guys
in America he's the goddamn Naked Gun
[Music]
what the [__] is going on right now
[Music] this is so stupid this is the most
careless police officer in the world thank
you [Music]
that's ridiculous
oh it's gonna be a fun time
I did hear he was in this years ago
all 40 kilos final shipment in three days
then we'll expect pain don't worry all right
you put those headphones on at the right time
[Music] [Laughter] well done please throw
down your guns
[Music]
Ricardo Montalban can even recognize him in
the shadows kill him
[Music]
oh no
[Laughter] this is my kind of Comedy there
he is he's like a National Treasure I did
it for her I did everything for her and now
she's gone and you came down here to get the
hot story didn't you Frank they're not here
for you Weird Al Yankovic is on the plane
everywhere I look something reminds me of
her
what about nordberg I came as soon as I heard
he's alive Frank though he's on life support
doctors say he's got a 50 50 chance of living
well it's only a 10 chance of that what
nordberg it's me Frank your buddy oh wow now
who did this to you I love you ship oh when
you're better we'll go sailing together on
a boat we'll take a cruise just like last
year drugs hey nurse give this man some drugs
heroin heroin Frank Norberg that's a pretty
tall owner you're gonna have to give me a
couple of days
never let a doubt enter your mind he's right
Wilma but I wouldn't wait until the last minute
to fill out those organ donor cards you're
a horrible Frank whatever scum did this that
one man on this force will rest for one minute
until he's Behind Bars now let's grab a bite
to eat yeah hahaha this delivery is perfect
thank you your honor protecting the safety
of the queen is a task that gladly accepted
by police dog or no matter how silly the idea
of having a queen might be to us
a Goodwill tour is it didn't remove the microphone
all right indeed it is for all the people
who will be able to share in the uh celebration
I've never I've always queezed the sound of
people urinating Ed and I drove down to the
docks where nordberg had been found floating
face down on the water in the case doesn't
make sense you know good policeman from bright
future
my memory ain't so great oh yeah maybe this
will refresh your memory I don't know it's
still kind of hazy how about this yeah I remember
him I used to see him around why do you want
to know I can't tell you that well maybe this
will help but you don't think I should yeah
you still don't think [Laughter]
all right all righty work at Ludwig shipping
he tried to push something on one of my boys
I swear it so what are you gonna do about
it copper why should I tell you maybe this
will help is stupid how about now all right
I'm going down to Ludwig's office I'll find
out if you're telling the truth [Laughter]
that was great Lieutenant the feeling is mutual
the Japanese fighting fish a beautiful graceful
elegant yet single-minded of purpose and deadly
Hmm this is a rare Samurai pen a gift from
Emperor Hirohito unbreakable impervious to
Everything But Water Everything But Water
I'm investigating the attempted murder of
one of your dog Parkers
fortunately the bullets missed every vital
organ in the salt water preserved him until
he was found so they were able to
there is no room in my organization criminal
activity a vast commercial development built
by me do you have any idea what was out there
just five years ago yeah you bet you do let
me get some Kleenex has this officer what's
his name uh Norbert oh no what have you done
uh well of course uh he hasn't been able to
tell us a thing uh so far but as soon as he
regains uh consciousness we'll see if he's
stupid
I'll have my assistant provide you with anything
you need you've been very cooperative [Music]
hahaha
I've heard police Works dangerous it is that's
why I carry a big gun aren't you afraid it
might go off accidentally I used to have that
problem and what did you do about it I just
think about baseball
I wish there was some way I could repay you
uh how about dinner I know this little out
of the way place that serves great Viking
food Viking food huh get to know Lieutenant
Dragon a little better find out what he knows
I have a responsibility to the stockholders
yes I'll do my best go on the date it was
about 4 P.M when I returned to police [Laughter]
pick the names of everybody here for questioning
uh I gotta get uh inside he's perfect man
we're testing that new Andy graffiti wall
set to react when the spray hits the sensor
good work Ted will you laugh boys think up
next now that you mentioned it I've already
just rented they're not just cufflinks each
one fires a single pin sized Dart that knocks
out your victim for a few minutes but does
no permanent damage
oh no he's gonna knock out someone he shouldn't
I can't see anything use your open eye Frank
hahaha
are you saying that nordberg is it I'm telling
you that the queen arrives here The Day After
Tomorrow the Press should pick this up with
nordberg still part of the force could be
embarrassing to the police and the city I'm
sorry Frank I'm giving you 24 hours to clear
nordberg 24 hours that's merely not enough
time who is the most effective assassin one
who doesn't know he's an assassin service
for two please
foreign
will that be with cream and sugar sir cream
only please that would be a great assassin
I had 24 hours to come up with something that
would clear my good friend's name oh my God
I'll be with you when I finish with Mr norber
yes doctor
[Music] had a lot of here and a couple of
oh no where's the police officers I got at
that door oh uh Lieutenant Trevin called and
sent him home I must kill nordberg [Music]
oh my God [Music]
come on that black car it's definitely check
her mirror signal now pull into traffic you
got this Stephanie I know a shortcut turn
left here
there he is easy
normally you would not be going 65 down the
wrong way of a one-way Street
yikes [Applause] [Music]
[Music] [Applause] [Music]
what the [__] [Music] [Laughter]
the attempt at nordberg's life left me shaken
and Disturbed who is this character in the
hospital why was he trying to
why was the I love you not listed in Ludwig's
records and if it was did he know about it
and if he didn't who did and where the hell
was I
or I just wanted a glass of Bosco and then
slip under my blankets but my knight was just
about to begin foreign
whoa he really did that role [Music] he really
did that flip
[Music]
[Laughter] [Music]
okay well hello there I've been hurt before
Oh I loved her but she had her music don't
recall her playing an instrument or being
able to carry a tune yet she was on the road
300 days out of the year No in fact I bought
her a heart for Christmas she asked me what
it was [Laughter] just something I ought to
tell you no what's in the past it doesn't
matter anyway two lonely Souls who have found
each other that's nice I want you to know
it practice safe [Music] [Laughter]
oh Jesus no way [Music]
do you have 24 hours to solve the case you're
spending too much time partying and she told
me
oh no
laugh because I'll call you tomorrow
[Laughter]
it's very so funny man
bingo
uh to pretend to be sophisticated 40 million
deposited on many banks Zurich upon proof
of Queen's death
they're gonna kill the queen
[Music]
I just knocks it all over [Music]
oh get out of there man
get out of there [Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music] whoa no way
[Music]
destroying properties are some sexual assault
with a concrete what the hell were you doing
there I don't want any more trouble like you
had last year on the South Side well when
I see five weirdos dressed in toga stabbing
a guy in the middle of the park and full view
of a hundred people I shoot the bastards that's
my policy that was a Shakespeare in the park
production [Laughter] actors good ones it's
your honor good ones this delivery is impeccable
I can't imagine anyone else doing this role
this is perfect I think that Vincent Ludwig's
involved in a number of criminal activity
Vincent Ludwig is a well-respected generous
kind man it's just too bad you don't know
him like I do oh yeah and how's that what's
that supposed to mean you know exactly what
it means he wants you to meet with the Seventh
Street Stockyards near the 53rd Street entrance
oh ah I gotta go I'll see you tomorrow are
you sure you want to have something to eat
what was going on that's creepy
[Music] I'm sorry I can't hear you don't fire
the gun while you're talking
foreign
trading shots with one of Ludwig's goons they're
planning on doing it tonight at here security
oh yeah what about this you think we were
born yesterday you didn't do anything he's
got a picture of your wife Ethel
all right anyone else here seeing his wife
that's all right that's okay [Laughter]
he's got like this great delivery of perfect
handle on the physical comedy too I don't
know what you're talking about my Stockyard
meaning butter wings or don't you remember
setting that up but Mr Ludwig said you call
a meeting off believe me find me another one
no she's innocent cops and women don't mix
like eating a spoonful of Drano sure it'll
clean you out it'll leave you hollow inside
too bad Sugar Puffs [Music] generously donated
by Mr Vincent Queen Elizabeth II
[Music]
foreign
it's disgusting the way they Splash this stuff
all over the newspapers what is journalism
coming to you it's just a bunch of different
positions logbook is planning to have someone
assassinate the queen you I don't want you
to risk this for me I'll go alone no this
is going to get you back on the force Frank
we're all right behind you the boys in blue
Queens attend baseball games
excuse me
Judo chop Mr Palazzo yes I'm the head Usher
will now sing our national anthem oh boy what
a disguise [Music] [Laughter] this is embarrassing
[Applause] oh no [Music]
[Laughter]
oh my God we're gonna do this today
Al it's Frank
you all right let's see if they're uniforms
straight [Applause] you should take a large
a little tighten the crotch all right all
set
[Laughter] [Applause] is that Anthony Edwards
[Applause]
call it strike [Applause] [Laughter] [Applause]
oh man he's not he's not running this game
at all is he
stop
[Music]
interesting
so many fun props in this movie [Music] [Applause]
I know this is hard to believe but apparently
the umpires have got foshone in a rundown
oh even the guy running a scoreboard up there
says he was out
in the third out
time
I must kill the queen I must kill the queen
oh no
sir
now we're going to take you for a walk it
brought an Uzi
[Applause]
America oh God that one guy I must kill the
queen [Applause] oh yeah that's right the
cufflinks oh no the wrong person
he saved the Queen's life it's Enrico Palazzo
laughs
[Applause] [Music]
it's really tossing around what the hell is
that adult I'm going to kill you two can play
at that game [Music]
hey ort you killed him oh no he just stunned
he'll be all right in a couple of minutes
oh no
well
[Laughter] Rose
[Music] these bits this game of tops [Music]
oh no what I must kill Frank Travis no no
don't shoot you don't love me then you might
as well pull that trigger because without
you I wouldn't want to live anyway really
finally found someone I can love good cleaner
without utensils
but don't you dance
it's an engagement ring I would have given
it to you earlier but I wanted to wait until
we were alone Frank
I'm sorry [Laughter] Monday morning we want
you back at police squad there's someone else
here who wants to thank you nurberg hi you
buddy he lives I forgot about him wonderful
whoa Prince
Wowie
foreign
I was genuinely hilarious
I don't recognize any of these man and woman
deleted from fireworks
even these credits are funny holy [__]
re-recorded re-recorded
it
divorce attorney
s Matt bakes [Laughter]
so funny in case of tornado holy [__]
[Laughter] that's so funny that was great
I I really enjoyed it that was so funny let's
talk about it that was a hilarious movie that
was so funny so funny it was a great spoof
of like film Noir detective movies seems like
it's kind of making fun of James Bond a little
bit too um but I I love this type of escalating
uh absurdist humor because it had this what
I really noticed in the bits especially with
the way Leslie Nielsen plays this role is
because yeah like he's got that brilliant
deadpan humor he plays everything so straight
no matter how absurd the situation gets he
plays everything's so straight and it's it's
remarkable just how impeccable the man's delivery
is because the physical bits that especially
his physical comedy is so well as so well
executed but then it's also his dialogue his
delivery there and he doesn't rely on like
insane amounts of energy or anything like
that and I I thought that it had this interesting
mix of like that great kind of comedic Snowball
Effect where everything just sort of builds
upon another bit another bit another bit and
even though a lot of the times the physicality
of things can be so outlandish there seemed
to be a sense of believability with some of
the physical painful injury bits and the response
to certain things I thought was great so we
knew how to blend both of those so well because
this this could have easily just felt like
a sketch but it still felt like a movie you
know like it didn't just feel like a bunch
of random bits and then they're like just
throw it in here just throw it in you're just
throw it in here it still felt like an actual
film which is the kind of spoof comedies that
I I sort of Miss and I'm surprised I've never
seen it like this at a lot of times people
are very much surprised I can't believe you
haven't seen this can't believe you've ever
seen this and then seeing how much this film
clicked with me and just knowing the kind
of con like we've done sketches here on the
channel and the kind of sketches we like to
do like to me I'm like this is the kind of
sketch comedy sort of material that I really
do uh particularly have a fancy for because
yeah all around the the way they handled every
single bit from just even something as simple
as like the dialogue exchange which is interrogating
that guy in the pier with the when they keep
passing the money back and forth to each other
because they're making fun of that bit when
they bribe the guy's subscribing Frank is
so stupid like the snow when he gets out of
the car and he starts shooting at the vehicle
and it's his own vehicle it's really like
is is like the direction and the editing is
is so well done it's it's very well calculated
because this kind of Comedy we've seen fail
um you know like around the the 2000s like
scary movie really had a a boom of all kinds
of comedy films I don't believe like Zucker
even took over I think these guys took over
for it's gonna be a franchise with I believe
I don't know how many they've done I was a
big fan of the franchise overall Scary Movie
um but you know you you had the Friedberg
and seltzer films which just did not get it
like they were they were just references you
know things like Meet the Spartans and whatever
like there were sometimes like a good Joker
there to be had but this is like the master
class version of what I feel like these spoof
comedies uh ought to have been like because
they still told a real narrative you know
you still had a real character here with Frank
because as even though the main the main goal
of the film is to make you laugh that's the
whole purpose of the movie is make you laugh
entertain your audience and that they like
they hit every every box every every box they
checked off in my opinion they did and but
you know setting it up with a character who's
going through what I think is is a separation
with his wife his wife leaving him and you
know that film Noir quality of uh can't trust
again and opening himself up looking for love
so having that Dynamic you you get this character
with a like who's who's stupid he's he's not
he's not the sharpest tool in the shed but
he's got a heart of gold and so that endears
you to the character and because Leslie Nielsen
seems to have like an understanding of that
that you know he could just he's really playing
the scenes versus just playing the jokes he's
really in the scene and he really has a character
here morphed and that's what makes it easier
to latch on to this performance and and get
lost in the world and where you have the comedy
bits that feel surprising because sometimes
you could see a joke coming but a lot of the
time I just couldn't see the joke coming and
you think nowadays like with a film from the
80s that the jokes would feel like a little
bit more predictable like there's there's
like sometimes the physical bits were a little
bit more obvious but it was really like the
dialogue and not even then no man I don't
want to say that because some sometimes sure
it's an 80 minute comedy so someone once in
a while you're gonna be like okay this is
that like when when OJ gets pushed down I
can't believe OJ Simpson OJ gets pushed down
the stairs at the very end and then flies
off to the baseball field like [__] like
that but more often than not you know like
the way they handle the again the build the
snowball effect of what he like does they're
making fun of the bit of what someone's broken
into my home and he like rolls forward and
the way they capture all it looks like Leslie
Nielsen really did that but he's just flipping
through his apartment like I didn't see that
bit coming and it just got kept getting bigger
and bigger and a lot of times you might see
a joke coming but when it gets so big that
sometimes the the the the the level of how
huge it got is the part I could not predict
whatsoever so yeah and I think um to have
Ricardo Montalban also play it very straight
without him trying to be funny helps just
to make the whole movie funnier and I think
that's a great comedic effect it's actually
really apt to have some like Weird Al Yankovic
cameo in a film like this but I think it's
really apt to have uh the the not app I think
it's really appropriate because a lot of times
in the in these comedy movies they try to
make everyone funny but a lot of times if
you have certain characters who are not aiming
to be funny it just makes the person who's
intended to be funny that much funnier so
the jokes land that much more because Ricardo
montalbomb plays it like a real villain and
again he's playing a real character even the
Jane character feels like she's being played
like a real like I love the way that they
actually decided to give her some real comedic
moments because I feel like a lot of times
with the the the the you know the leading
female character in a film like this it wouldn't
even really attempt that they would just try
to give it all a Leslie man but I really felt
like they gave her you know certain comedy
bits to really work with and a chance for
her to really Excel because she wasn't as
obviously funny uh but she definitely had
some really funny moments as well so yeah
I mean for a spoof comedy from the 80s I feel
like this holds up remarkably well especially
like with Leslie Nielsen's performance uh
I'm so impressed with what he's done I imagine
the man has to I think I've heard this before
because all I've really seen I I must have
seen more than just airplane uh from him uh
there's got to be other things I've seen him
and but none of them are coming to mind at
the moment but but you know like I think he
might have like a background in drama and
that just works so well you know and and it's
refreshing to get that where you have a dramatic
actor who understands comedy so well and the
way to do it is to play it with the utmost
seriousness and he Nails it like on every
corner like I think this was a a really great
comedy and I had an absolute blast watching
it for all the reasons I listened thought
they had great musical choices I think the
way they they knew how to edit a lot of these
scenes really goes to enhance like it's visual
comedy it doesn't just rely on the gag itself
like a lot of it has to do with the pinpoint
accuracy of knowing when to cut and what to
cut to and also how to work your camera and
of what to what roles in the frame it was
it was really well done I thought it was an
excellent excellent film I hope the sequels
are just as good because this was a hell of
a great time I thought it was so funny and
I love spoof I like com uh cop spoof films
a lot like in modern times I really love films
like the other guys I think that that is a
really funny bit but even that movie you can
tell really has a lot of scenes that are freaking
hysterical but rely more on improv and I never
got the sense that there was um a lot maybe
there was but I didn't get the sense that
there was improv it seemed like it had a really
calculated screenplay on their hands and every
actor was just doing what they could uphold
it because there's a lot of prop comedy here
too and uh I thought they were those were
all used to Great bits as well so yeah every
everything all around was was funny there's
a lot of unexpected jokes and a lot of hilarious
moments and Leslie Nielsen was excellent so
yeah I'm glad I watched this film thank you
guys for being here with me thank you for
all who recommended this my way because this
was an absolute Delight I had a I had a ball
of a Time thank you guys Dan B Sure almost
ended the video be sure to subscribe and leave
a like and all those things that you're supposed
to say at the end of one of these YouTube
videos [Music]